O
DO WITH UFOS SO, YES, I'M INTO
IT WE HAVE A LOT TO TALK.
ABOUT THE WHOLE SHOW JUST
CHANGED, --
IT SURE DID.
>> JOHN, OUR DEBATES STILL
RELEVANT IN HELPING VOTERS
CHOOSE CANDIDATES, OR ARE THEY
POLITICAL THEATER AT THIS POINT?
>> YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I LOVE
THEATER.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS YES STAB
THING.
THEY ARE POLITICAL THEATER.
IT'S POLITICAL THEATER THAT
MATTERS SOME.
I THINK THE HIGHLY NUANCED
TONIGHT, EVERYTHING --
TO DEBATES.
LOOK, WE ARE ALSO SO POLARIZED
RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN PEOPLE GO
INTO WATCH A DEBATE WHEN
THEY'RE MORE SET THAN THEY
MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
THERE AREN'T AS MANY SOURCE
WEIGHT WILL VOTERS WATCHING.
HOWEVER, I DO THINK ON THE
MARGINS, DEPENDING ON THE RACE.
THEY CAN HAVE CONSEQUENCES, I
KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT FLORIDA,
YOU HAVE RON DESANTIS AGAINST
CHARLIE CRIST, MAYBE IT WON'T
TURN THE TIDE IN THAT RACE DOWN
THERE.
BUT RON DESANTIS, HE WANTS TO
BE DOING THINGS.
MAYBE OTHER THINGS A FEW YEARS
FROM NOW.
MAYBE SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
ON --
SOME IMPACT DOWN THE LINE.
>> IT MIGHT PERSUADE PEOPLE
BETWEEN 2024, HE'S ALLUDING.
TWO IN TERMS OF WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS ONE OF THE
FIRST TIMES IN RECENT YEARS,
THE FLORIDA GOVERNOR'S RACE HAS
BEEN AS MUCH OF A LEAD FOR THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE --
AND I WONDER, GIVEN THAT IT
SEEMS TO BE THE TRAJECTORY THAT
IT IS, IS THIS THAT HE'S
ADDITION FOR 2024, IS THERE
SOMETHING TO LOSE RIGHT?
NOW >> HE IS MISSION IN FOR
2024, BUT IN A DEBATE, YOU
DON'T WANT TO MAKE MISTAKES.
IF YOU MAKE A BAD MISTAKES, YOU
CAN STUMBLE BACK AND THAT CAN
HURT YOU.
AS LONG AS YOU DON'T MAKE ANY
BIG GAFFES OR ERRORS YOU SHOULD
BE FINE, THIS WON'T CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY, DESANTIS IS GONNA
WIN, HE'S ON A STAGE AND HE'S
ABOUT 2020.
FOR >> LET'S PLAY THIS MORNING
THIS MOMENT.
HE WAS ASKED DIRECTLY, IF HE
WOULD SERVE FOUR-YEAR TERM AS
GOVERNOR.
>> YOU'RE RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR.
LOOK IN THE EYES OF THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
AND SAY TO THEM, IF YOU'RE
REELECTED, YOU'LL SERVE A FULL
FOUR-YEAR TERM AS GOVERNOR, YES
OR NO?
[APPLAUSE] >> YES OR NO, RON?
WILL YOU SERVE A FULL FOUR-YEAR
TERM IF YOU'RE ELECTED GOVERNOR?
IT'S NOT A TOUGH QUESTION?
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION, HE WON'T
TELL.
YOU >> WE DID NOT AGREE ON THE
CANDIDATES ASKING EACH OTHER
QUESTIONS, GOVERNOR.
IT'S YOUR?
TURN >> LISTEN, I KNOW CHARLIE
IS GONNA TALK ABOUT 2024.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE THINGS VERY,
VERY CLEAR.
THE ONLY WORN OUT, OLD ON THE
I'M LOOKING TO PUT OUT THE
PASTURE IS CHARLIE CRIST.
>> SO, DOES THAT HELP IT OR
DOES THAT HURT HIM THAT HE
WON'T ANSWER WHETHER OR NOT?
>> I THINK WITH HIS BASE, IT
PROBABLY HELPS.
I THINK EVERYONE WHO LOVES
RHONDA SANTAS, LOVES THE FACT
THAT HE'S NOW THIS NATIONAL
FIGURE, THEY THINK IT PROBABLY
BRINGS MORE PRESTIGE TO FLORIDA,
IT WILL GIVE HIM MORE POWER IF
HE DOES GET REELECTED, SO I
THINK THIS DEBATE TONIGHT
PROBABLY DIDN'T --
BUT IT'S ALSO LIKE ONE OF THOSE
ROAD SHOCKED HAS, TO TALK TO
THE DESANTIS CAMPAIGN.
THEY THINK HE OBLITERATED
CHRIS.
YOU TALK TO THE CHRIS CAMPAIGN
THEY THINK HE OBLITERATED
DESANTIS.
IT DID NEED TO BE ONE WHERE IT
DID CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY FOR
CHRIS, GIVEN WHERE HE IS IN THE
POLLS.
AND WHILE I DO THINK FROM WHAT
I HEAR, WHAT I'VE SEEN CRIST
DID DO WELL.
IN THE PLACES WHERE I THINK HE
REALLY NEEDED TO UNDERSCORE,
THE EXTREME NATURE OF
DESANTIS'S AGENDA.
IN TERMS OF ABORTION, IN TERMS
OF LGBTQ, IN TERMS OF DENYING
HISTORY FOR THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS, BUT THINGS
THAT CRIST DID A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF UNDERSCORING.
AND MAYBE IT DOES MATTER IN THE
MARGINS, I DON'T THINK THE
MARGINS ARE GONNA BE BIG ENOUGH
TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
>> TAKE A STEP BACK, FOUR OUT
OF FLORIDA FOR A MOMENT.
I KNOW THERE'S FOCUS ON SELECT
RACES.
BUT MORE BROADLY, ARE WE REALLY
SAYING THAT WE ARE AS AN
ELECTORATE, WERE SO ENTRENCHED
IN OUR HEELS, THAT WE
ESSENTIALLY THINK OF THESE
RACES AND THE DEBATES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE OPPORTUNITIES
TO FIGURE OUT --
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY HAD
THEIR MINDS MADE UP.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, WHAT'S WITH
ALL THE ADS.
THESE ADS ARE COMING OUT OF THE
WOODWORK, RIGHT?
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE THINKING,
HEY, HOLD ON I CAN MAYBE GET
THIS MUSLIM PERSON TO CHANGE
THEIR MIND.
>> I'VE BEEN A PLAY A LOT OF
ELECTION NIGHTS, OVER THE LAST
TWO, FOUR, SIX YEARS, THEY TURN
TO ELECTION WEEKS.
SOME OF THESE RACES ARE WICKED
CLOSE AS WE LIKE TO SAY IN
BOSTON.
SO, I THINK EVEN THOUGH 96% OF
THE PEOPLE SHOWING UP AT THE
POLLS MAY BE THAT SAT ON THEIR
VOTE.
THERE IS THE TINIEST SLIVER, AS
MY GRANDMOTHER WOULD SAY, A
SLIVER OF THE VOTING POPULATION
OUT THERE.
I WAS WAITING, WATCHING, AND
CAN BE SWAYED BY SOMETHING.
PEOPLE DON'T WATCH SET IT AND
MOVE IT THE WAY THEY WATCH.
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES THE
NUMBERS FROM THESE DEBATES
AREN'T GONNA BE A TO WHAT THEY
ARE.
THE EARLY NUMBERS --
BUT MAYBE FOR THAT REASON --
>> IT SEEPS INTO THE HEADLINES
IT, SEEPS INTO THE HEADLINES OF
THE PAPERS FOR A FEW DAYS.
AND IT COULD BE A GOOD THING.
I THINK WHEN YOU ARE TALKING --
FEWER THAN 10,000 VOTES.
WHAT YOU GUYS KNOW, THEY CAN
BE.
>> A LOT OF THEM TODAY THAT
CAN.
>> THERE'S STILL AN IMPACTFUL
NUMBER OF SWING VOTERS OUT
THERE.
NOT AS MANY AS THEY USED TO BE.
BUT THERE IS ENOUGH.
SOME OF THESE RACES ARE GONNA
COME DOWN TO THE WIRE.